This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you've ever driven into New York City from the north, there's a good chance you pass by a massive cluster of high-rise apartment buildings just as you enter the Bronx. 35 buildings in total, all of them with identical brick facades, all over 20 stories tall. I remember the first time I saw these buildings, riding a Greyhound bus into the city from Worcester. Massachusetts. 99PI producer of Meredith's Katie Mingle is back to tell our story this week. I was in my early 20s at the time, and I'd never really seen skyscrapers that weren't office buildings. These buildings, I could tell, were people's homes. I could see laundry hanging on
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你曾开车从北面进入纽约市，很有可能会在刚进入布朗克斯区时，路过一片庞大的高层公寓群。总共35栋建筑，全都有着一模一样的砖砌外墙，高度全部超过20层。我还记得我第一次看到这些建筑时的情景，当时我正坐着灰狗巴士，从马萨诸塞州的伍斯特市驶入纽约。99PI的制作人凯蒂·明格尔的梅雷迪斯今天回归，为我们讲述本周的故事。我当时二十岁出头，从没见过不是办公楼的摩天大楼。我一眼就能看出，这些建筑是人们的家。我能看到衣服挂在
balconies way up on like the 22nd floor. There was something thrilling, but also almost frightening about contemplating the number of individual lives playing out. in just one of those skyscrapers. It had the effect of making me feel very small and insignificant. The way looking at something incomprehensibly large can sometimes do. I think I assumed at the time that what I was looking at was a public housing project. But I know now that it wasn't. This cluster of high rises was and is the largest housing cooperative in the world, Co-op City.
大约22层那么高的阳台上。思考着其中一栋摩天大楼里正在上演的无数个人生，这种感觉既惊心动魄，又几乎有点令人恐惧。它让我觉得自己非常渺小和微不足道。就像凝视某种大得超乎想象的事物时有时会产生的感觉一样。我想我当时以为我看到的是一个公共住房项目。但我现在知道并不是。这个高层住宅群过去是，现在也是世界上最大的住房合作社——合作城。
When Co-op City opened in the late 1960s, people hated the way it looked. Journalists and architecture critics thought the buildings embodied everything that was wrong with modernist architecture. Newsweek said, quote, The Towers of New York City's Co-op City rise bleak and spectrally through the smog, a prospect so remote and cheerless that affluent commuters often shudder when they pass it. Those comments are exactly why Co-op City is the best kept secret because it's like hiding in plain sight. This is Diane Patrick.
当合作城在20世纪60年代末落成时，人们讨厌它的外观。记者和建筑评论家认为，这些建筑体现了现代主义建筑的所有弊端。《新闻周刊》曾写道：“纽约合作城的塔楼在雾霾中显得阴冷而幽暗，前景如此遥远而凄凉，以至于富裕的通勤者经过时往往会不寒而栗。”这些评论正是合作城成为最好保守的秘密的原因，因为它就像是藏在眼皮底下。这是黛安·帕特里克。
She lives in Co-op City. You look at the exterior, you make your judgment, and you just keep moving, and you don't give it another thought. Diane moved into her Co-op City apartment in 1978. I think I paid $2,500 for the apartment. Diane doesn't pay rent. But she doesn't exactly own the unit either. Technically, when she handed over that $2,500, she was buying a share in a corporation.
她住在合作城。你看看外观，做出你的判断，然后继续赶路，不再多想。黛安于1978年搬进了她在合作城的公寓。我想我当时为这套公寓支付了2500美元。黛安不付房租。但她也不完全拥有这套住房。严格来说，当她交出那2500美元时，她买的是一家公司的股份。
This is how co-ops work. The housing development itself is a corporation. And when you buy a share, you are buying the right to live in a specific unit. Together, all the residents of a cooperative collectively own the corporation that is their building. Do you feel like you're an owner? Like, does that... Yes. We can do things inside our unit.
这就是合作公寓的运作方式。住房开发项目本身就是一个公司。当你购买股份时，你买的是居住在特定单元的权利。合作社的所有居民共同拥有作为他们大楼的这家公司。你觉得自己像个业主吗？就像，这……是的。我们可以在我们的单元内部做任何
whatever we want. We do our own painting and flooring and whatever improvements we want to do. On top of that initial $2,500 investment, every month Diane pays what are called carrying charges. For Diane, these are about $800 a month, and they cover the mortgage and utilities like heat, electricity, and air conditioning.
我们想做的事。我们自己刷墙、铺地板，做任何我们想做的改进。除了最初的2500美元投资外，黛安每月还要支付所谓的管理费。对黛安来说，这笔费用大约是每月800美元，涵盖了房贷以及暖气、电力和空调等公用设施。
How big is your apartment? Like, what does it look like? It's gorgeous. I think it's like 850 square feet. It's large and it's beautiful. And it's large and it's beautiful. Diane used to work in real estate. So she's particularly aware of how lucky she is
你的公寓有多大？看起来是什么样的？太棒了。我想大概有850平方英尺。它又大又美。而且它又大又美。黛安曾在房地产行业工作。因此，她格外清楚自己是多么幸运
to have a place she likes at a price she can afford. I saw what people were paying for tiny, teeny, teeny little apartments in Manhattan. You know, you'd have to have a big pile of money. endless money because they're not made for people who are just ordinary people. Not made for ordinary people. I know what Diane is getting at here. In major cities like New York, sometimes it feels like there's public housing for low-income families
能以自己负担得起的价格买到喜欢的地方。我看到人们在曼哈顿为那些极其微型的小公寓付出了多少钱。你知道的，你得有一大笔钱，无休止的钱，因为它们不是为普通人建造的。不是为普通人建造的。我明白黛安的意思。在纽约这样的大城市里，有时你会觉得，这里既有面向低收入家庭的公共住房，
and market rate housing that is insanely expensive with not much in-between. Co-op City, though, is that in between in-between in a couple of different ways. It's in-between renting and owning, and it offers some of the per-courable. of both. It's also in between in terms of cost. Co-op City was specifically intended to be affordable for middle-class New Yorkers. In fact, it was part of a whole movement to build this kind of in-between middle-class housing. Co-op City was the crowning achievement of that movement, and also the end of it.
也有天价的市场价住房，而中间的选择却不多。不过，合作城正是这种中间选择，它在几个不同的方面都处于中间地位。它介于租房和买房之间，兼具两者的部分优点。在成本方面，它也处于中间状态。合作城最初的定位就是让中产阶级的纽约人能够负担得起。事实上，它是建设这种介于中间的中产阶级住房运动的一部分。合作城是那场运动的最高成就，也是它的终点。
This story begins with a Russian immigrant named Abraham Kaysen. In the early 1900s, Kaysen was a young socialist and a union organizer. But what he was really passionate about actually went beyond the normal work of unions. He was very interested in cooperatives. This is Joshua Freeman. He's a historian who's written about labor and housing. This was a viable alternative to capitalism, to market systems, that you could sort of develop within an existing capital society. Kaysen pursued a few different cooperative ventures before turning to. his attention to the thing that would become his life's work. Housing. At this point,
这个故事始于一个名叫亚伯拉罕·凯森的俄罗斯移民。在20世纪初，凯森是一个年轻的社会主义者和工会组织者。但他真正热衷的事情实际上超出了工会的常规工作。他对合作社非常感兴趣。这是约书亚·弗里曼。他是一位撰写过关于劳工和住房历史的学者。这是资本主义、市场系统的一种可行替代方案，你可以在现有的资本主义社会内部发展这种方案。凯森在将注意力转向成为他终身事业的事业之前，曾追求过几个不同的合作社风险项目。住房。此时，
he's an organizer for the Amalgamated Clothing Workers Union of America, which represented garment workers. These garment workers were mostly living on the lowry side in these cramped, unhealthy, run-down slum tenements. By 1920 or so, Kaysen was convinced that the union should help get rid of the predatory landlords who owned these tenements. He thought, thought that the union should construct its own apartment buildings and let its members become collective owners. This was cooperative housing, and it was actually a concept that New Yorkers already understood. The origins of co-ops don't come from the working or radical milieu. This was something like rich people came up with.
他是美国联合服装工人工会的一名组织者，该工会代表服装工人。这些服装工人大多住在下东区那些拥挤、不健康、破烂不堪的贫民窟公寓里。到1920年前后，凯森确信工会应该帮助清除拥有这些公寓的掠夺性房东。他认为，工会应该建造自己的公寓楼，并让其成员成为共同所有者。这就是合作住房，这其实是一个纽约人已经理解的概念。合作社的起源并非来自工人阶级或激进阶层。这是富人想出来的主意。
You know, I'm sitting in a co-op building right now. I live in a building with about 100 apartments and the 100 of, Us residents, we collectively own this building, but it's middle class and upper middle class building. And if someone moves out, they sell their apartment where they think of is selling the apartment. They really selling the shares in the corporation, you know, on the open market. And if they sell it for more than they bought it, more power to them, they got to keep the money. But that's not how Kaysen envisioned his co-ops working. In the kind of co-ops he wanted to build, when people moved out and sold their share in the corporation, they get back the money they put in.
你知道，我现在正坐在一栋合作公寓大楼里。我住的这栋楼有大约100套公寓，我们这100名居民共同拥有这栋楼，但这是一栋中产阶级和中上阶级的大楼。如果有人搬走，他们会出售他们的公寓，或者他们认为是在出售公寓。他们实际上是在公开市场上出售公司里的股份。如果他们以高于买入价的价格卖出，那是他们的本事，他们可以保留这笔钱。但凯森设想的合作社运作方式并非如此。在他想要建造的合作社里，当人们搬走并出售他们在公司里的股份时，他们只能拿回自己投入的钱，
but they wouldn't make a profit. Removing profit would ensure the building stayed affordable into the future. Bikazen said at first, the Union Brass wasn't all that interested in his cooperative housing idea. Here he is in an interview that he did late in his life. For a long while, I was the laughing stock in the organization when I spoke about building cooperative housing. All my close friends used to make fun of me. Haters be damned by the late 1920s, Kaysen and various union partners had built three new cooperative buildings that housed more than 850 working class families.
但不会从中获利。消除利润将确保这栋建筑在未来依然价格亲民。凯森曾说，起初，工会高层对他的合作住房理念并不怎么感兴趣。这里有他晚年做的一段采访录音。在很长一段时间里，当我谈到建造合作住房时，我是组织里的笑柄。我所有亲密的朋友都拿我开涮。让那些反对者见鬼去吧。到20世纪20年代末，凯森和多位工会伙伴已经建造了三栋新的合作公寓楼，为850多户工人阶级家庭提供了住房。
During the Great Depression and World War II, the work of building cooperative housing, or any housing for that matter, mostly just stopped. Which is why, after World War II, New York, along with a lot of urban America, found itself in a pretty acute housing shortage. In 1949, the federal government passed the American Housing Act to help fix it. The new legislation had provisions to promote homeownership and the construction of public housing. And it also provided a bunch of money to clear blighted neighborhoods, or so-called slums. If we don't clean out these slums, the central areas are going to rock. There are very few cases where genuine slums, can be fixed up in any other way than by tearing them down.
在大萧条和第二次世界大战期间，建造合作住房或任何住房的工作基本上都停滞了。这就是为什么在二战之后，纽约以及许多美国城市发现自己面临着相当严重的住房短缺。1949年，联邦政府通过了《美国住房法》来帮助解决这一问题。新立法规定了促进房屋所有权和公共住房建设的条款。它还提供了一大笔资金来清理荒废的街区，也就是所谓的贫民窟。如果我们不清除这些贫民窟，中心区就会腐烂。极少数情况下，真正的贫民窟能够通过除了拆除之外的其他任何方式得到修复。
That, of course, is Robert Moses, New York City's most prolific and problematic city planner. As die-hard fans of the show will know, Robert Moses did more to reshape New York City in the 20th century than probably any other single person. After the American Housing Act was passed, Moses became head of New York City's slum clearance committee. Part of what Moses wanted to do was replace these blighted,
当然，那是罗伯特·摩西，纽约市最多产也最具争议的城市规划师。作为本节目的死忠粉都知道，罗伯特·摩西对20世纪纽约市面貌的重塑，其影响可能超过了其他任何单个人。在《美国住房法》通过后，摩西成为了纽约市贫民窟清除委员会的主席。摩西想要做的事情之一，就是用公共住房取代这些破败的
buildings with public housing. And in the post-war years, he did oversee the construction of a lot of public housing for low-income renters. But he and others in government also wanted housing for the middle class. In most other places, municipal governments sort of pursue like a two-pronged strategy for building new housing after World War II. This is Anne-Marie Sammartino. She's a professor of history at Oberlin College. On the one hand, there's housing projects for the very poor that are in the urban core. And then there's single family, you know, sort of mortgage support for single family homes. New York's a little bit different because the mayor and other people in city government, they want to keep the middle class. And when they're saying this, they don't
建筑。在战后几年里，他确实监督建造了许多面向低收入租房者的公共住房。但他和政府中的其他人也希望为中产阶级建造住房。在大多数其他地方，市政府在二战后为建设新住房采取了一种双管齐下的战略。这是安妮-玛丽·萨马蒂诺。她是欧柏林学院的历史学教授。一方面，有位于城市核心区的、面向极度贫困人群的住房项目。然后是针对单户住宅的抵押贷款支持。纽约的情况略有不同，因为市长和市府其他官员希望把中产阶级留在市内。当他们这么说时，他们并不仅仅
just mean the white middle class, but they mostly mean the white middle class living in New York City. But it wasn't easy to find developers who wanted to get into the business of slum clearance in order to build homes for the middle class. On the shortlist of groups willing to do the work were the unions and socialists. They'd already started building housing cooperatives and blighted neighborhoods and were anxious to build more.
并不完全指白人中产阶级，他们主要指的是住在纽约市的白人中产阶级。但是，要找到愿意涉足清除贫民窟以建房给中产阶级的开发商并不容易。愿意做这项工作的候选名单上有工会和社会主义者。他们已经开始在衰败的社区建造住房合作社，并渴望建造更多。
And the person most associated with this movement was our guy, Abraham Kaysen. Kaysen and Moses were quite closely together and they realized that in a lot of ways they had overlapping visions for the future of the city, you know, that both of them wanted to replace slums with better housing. In 1951, Kaysen created an organization dedicated to doing just that. It was called the United Housing Foundation, or UHF.
与这场运动最相关的人物就是我们的人，亚伯拉罕·凯森。凯森和摩西紧密合作，他们意识到在很多方面，他们对城市未来的愿景是不谋而合的，你知道，他们两个都想用更好的住房取代贫民窟。1951年，凯森创立了一个专门致力于实现这一目标的组织，名为联合住房基金会（UHF）。
And it's an alliance, basically, of existing cooperative projects, of unions and working past fraternal groups. So, you know, they band together to create the UHF. And Kaysen is like, you know, the leader. I mean, he's got lieutenants, but he's the guy. Then in 1955, New York State created a program called Mitchell Lama. It gave private developers like the UHF more incentive to build middle class housing by offering them low interest rate mortgages and tax breaks.
它基本上是一个由现有合作项目、工会和过去的工人兄弟会组成的联盟。所以，你知道，他们联合起来创建了UHF。而凯森就像是，你知道的，领袖。我是说，他有副手，但他才是核心人物。接着在1955年，纽约州创立了一个名为米切尔-拉玛的项目。它通过提供低息贷款和税收减免，为像UHF这样的私营开发商建造中产阶级住房提供了更多激励。
For a wonky government program, Mitchell Lama is still weirdly well known in New York. And one of the many answers people might give to the question, where did you grow up? Like, I grew up in a brownstone. I grew up in the projects. I grew up in a Mitchell Lama. If I may take us on a very quick digression to prove my point. Here is Timothy Shalamee on Theo Vaughn's podcast back in 2024. Same thing, man.
作为一个复杂的政府项目，米切尔-拉玛在纽约依然出奇地知名。人们在被问到“你在哪里长大？”时，可能会给出许多答案之一，例如：我是在褐石公寓长大的，我是在政府廉租房长大的，我是在米切尔-拉玛公寓长大的。如果允许我稍微扯远一点来证明我的观点，这里是蒂莫西·柴勒梅德在2024年吉奥·沃恩播客节目中的访谈。就是这样，老兄。
I grew up in like a Mitchell Lama. You know about Mitchell Lama? Oh, yeah, the restaurant stars or whatever. No, no, no, no, no. The Mitchell Lama is like... At this point in the interview, Timothy does a pretty bad job of explaining what Mitchell Lama is. but he gets one of the main things right. It was meant to be housing for people of moderate income.
我是在类似于米切尔-拉玛的地方长大的。你知道米切尔-拉玛吗？哦，是的，餐厅的明星还是什么的。不，不，不，不，不。米切尔-拉玛是像……在采访的这个阶段，蒂莫西对米切尔-拉玛是什么的解释相当糟糕，但他有一点说对了。它原本是为中等收入人群提供的住房。
Oh, that damn Mitchell Lama, brother. Absolutely. Oh, that's me, baby, moderate. Mitchell Lama was launched in an era of big government liberalism. The state was subsidizing not just housing for the poor, but for people of middle income, like construction workers and teachers. In the Mitchell Lama years, the program would finance over 100,000 units of affordable housing,
哦，该死的米切尔-拉玛，兄弟。绝对的。哦，那就是我，宝贝，中产。米切尔-拉玛是在大政府自由主义时代推出的。当时不仅为穷人提供住房补贴，还为中等收入人群（如建筑工人和教师）提供补贴。在米切尔-拉玛的年代，该计划资助了超过10万套经济适用房，
for the middle class. Many of them would be cooperatives built by the United Housing Foundation. The United Housing Foundation started relatively small. They put up a couple of buildings in the Bronx, about 400 apartments in total. But at the opening ceremony for one of the buildings, Robert Moses said it wasn't enough that at the current rate, it would take 50 years to clear the city's slums. Abraham Kaysen got the message. The projects would only get bigger from there.
专门为中产阶级建造。其中许多是由联合住房基金会建造的合作公寓。联合住房基金会的起步相对较小。他们在布朗克斯建造了几栋建筑，总共约400套公寓。但在其中一栋建筑的落成典礼上，罗伯特·摩西表示这还不够，按照目前的速度，要清除这座城市的贫民窟需要50年。亚伯拉罕·凯森听进去了。从那时起，项目只会越做越大。
By the late 1950s, they had finished a project called the Penn South Cooperative, 10 buildings, all of them about 20 stories tall. It was an absolutely massive development in the Chelsea neighborhood of Manhattan. Penn South, an extraordinarily ambitious project, was built to provide decent housing for garment workers who could then walk to work, right? You know, talk about an urbanistic utopian vision. You know, that was it.
到了20世纪50年代末，他们完成了一个名为“宾夕法尼亚南区合作公寓”（Penn South Cooperative）的项目，共10栋建筑，每栋大约20层高。这是曼哈顿切尔西社区一个绝对宏大的开发项目。宾夕法尼亚南区是一个极其雄心勃勃的项目，旨在为服装工人提供体面的住房，这样他们就可以步行去上班，对吧？你知道，这就是所谓的城市乌托邦愿景。你知道，那就是它。
15,000 people came to the dedication ceremony for the Penn South Cooperative in 1962. In attendance was an absolute who's who of power brokerage. Robert Moses, of course, but also Nelson Rockefeller, who was governor of New York at the time. Eleanor Roosevelt was there and the president of the AFL-CIO, the president of the International Ladies Garment Workers Union, and oh yeah, the president of the United States of America, John F. Kennedy. This union deserves the hardiest commendation. I hope others will follow your example.
1962年，有1.5万人参加了宾夕法尼亚南区合作公寓的落成典礼。出席的堪称权贵云集。当然有罗伯特·摩西，还有时任纽约州长的纳尔逊·洛克菲勒。埃莉诺·罗斯福也出席了，还有美国劳联-产联主席、国际女装工会主席，噢对了，还有美利坚合众国总统约翰·F·肯尼迪。这个工会当之无愧地受到最热烈的表扬。我希望其他人能效仿你们的榜样。
And I come here today and ask you to continue to work. But it wasn't all sunshine and rainbows and housing for the working class. In the speeches that day between the self-congratulations, you can hear something else. The people responsible for building this massive housing development are defensive. They seem to feel embattled. Here's Abraham Kaysen at the podium. Contrary to the false impression that this type of redevelopment destroys existing neighborhoods, we are proud to say that developments like this remove from the city, a cancerous blight,
我今天来这里也是请求你们继续努力。但这并非全是阳光雨露和为工人阶级提供的住房。在那天自吹自擂的演讲中，你能听到一些别的东西。负责建造这个大规模住宅开发项目的人是有防御心理的。他们似乎觉得自己腹背受敌。以下是站在演讲台上的亚伯拉罕·凯森。与这种类型的重建会破坏现有社区的错误印象相反，我们自豪地宣布，像这样的开发项目为城市清除了一个毒瘤般的祸害，
the breeding ground of crime and delinquency in all other social ills. And here's Robert Moses, addressing the audience after Kaysen. I believe that when the dust of the housing, battles has settled, this cooperative non-profit village will go down in history. It is one of the very best. The housing battles Moses is referring to is likely the community opposition to the Penn South development and others like it. During each project, old neighborhoods had been destroyed and resonance displaced.
这里是犯罪、青少年 delinquency（违法乱纪）以及所有其他社会弊病的温床。接着是罗伯特·摩西，他在凯森之后向观众发表讲话。我相信，当住房之战的硝烟散去，这个合作非营利村庄将载入史册。它是最好的之一。摩西所指的住房之战，很可能是社区对宾夕法尼亚南区开发项目及其他类似项目的反对。在每个项目期间，旧社区都被摧毁，居民流离失所。
Robert Caro, author of the power broker, estimated that Moses evicted 250,000 people to build highways in New York City. and another 250,000 for urban renewal projects like slum clearance and housing development. Efforts to rehouse the displaced were half-hearted at best. Robert Moses was infamously dismissive of his detractors, saying once that the critics build nothing, and also this classic. You're never going to get unanimous approval. There must be people who are discommoted inconvenienced or call it what you will on the old theory,
《权力掮客》的作者罗伯特·卡罗估计，摩西为了在纽约市修建高速公路驱逐了25万人，为了城市更新项目（如清除贫民窟和住房开发）又驱逐了25万人。重新安置流离失所者的努力充其量只能算是敷衍了事。罗伯特·摩西对批评者的态度出了名的不屑一顾，他曾说过批评者什么也没建造，还有这个经典名言：你永远不可能获得一致同意。总会有人感到不便、困扰或随你怎么说，根据旧理论，
but you can't make an omelet without breaking some eggs. In the case of the Penn South Cooperative, the broken eggs were 354 homes demolished, 183 stores raised, and nearly 2,000 residents evicted. Those evicted residents could apply to live in the new cooperative buildings, but a lot of people couldn't afford it.
但是不做 omelet（煎蛋）就打不碎鸡蛋。就宾夕法尼亚南区合作公寓而言，被打碎的“鸡蛋”是354栋被拆除的住宅、183家被铲平的商店，以及近2000名被驱逐的居民。那些被驱逐的居民可以申请入住新的合作公寓，但很多人根本负担不起。
You know, union-sponsored nonprofit housing was affordable to a plumbent. or a garment worker with a steady job and a union contract. It was not necessarily affordable to a lower level of the working class. The poorer segment of slum dwellers were more likely to be African American or Puerto Rican. So, in fact, a lot of the union co-ops were almost all white. You know, I mean, in some cases, they were literally all white. They saw the world in kind of class terms.
你知道，工会资助的非营利住房对于水管工或拥有稳定工作和工会合同的服装工人来说是负担得起的。但对于更低阶层的工人阶级来说，它不一定负担得起。贫民窟中较穷的阶层更有可能是非裔美国人或波多黎各人。因此，事实上，许多工会合作公寓几乎全是白人。你知道，我的意思是，在某些情况下，它们字面意义上就是全白人。他们以某种阶级视角来看待世界。
Again, Anne-Marie San Martino. Now, of course, the world does not just exist in class terms. There's also racial dynamics here. And the leaders of the United Housing Foundation from the beginning were clear that they were fine with anybody of any racial background if they could afford to pay the equity deposit. The UHF was stubbornly philosophically committed to the equity deposit. They felt like this investment was a crucial piece of what they were building. This in-between housing that kept the middle. middle class in the city by offering them apartments they could afford and empowered them as co-owners.
再次引用安娜-玛丽·圣马蒂诺的话。当然，世界不仅仅存在阶级划分。这里面也有种族动态。联合住房基金会的领导层从一开始就很明确，只要能够支付产权押金，他们不介意任何种族背景的人入住。UHF在哲学上顽固地坚持产权押金制度。他们认为这种投资是他们正在建设的事业的关键部分。这种介于中间的住房，通过提供他们负担得起的公寓，将中产阶级留在了城市里，并赋予他们作为共同所有者的权力。
Because they saw that this gave people a stake in the community, that they would not have if they were mere renters in their minds. Apart from displaced community members, Robert Moses and the UHF had another prominent critic around this time, the writer and activist Jane Jacobs. And what she was saying is like, no, no, no, you know, these places that you're so quick to condemn, both physically condemn and like morally condemn, are actually functioning communities. And that when you build new housing, what you're doing is destroying community and you're building something sterile from which no community can emerge.
因为他们看到这赋予了人们对社区的归属感，而如果他们只是租客的话，在他们看来就不会有这种归属感。除了流离失所的社区成员，罗伯特·摩西和UHF在这一时期还有另一个著名的批评者——作家兼活动家简·雅各布斯。而她的观点是，不，不，不，你知道，这些你们急于谴责的地方——无论是从物理上还是从道德上谴责——实际上是功能健全的社区。当你建造新住房时，你所做的是在摧毁社区，并建造一个无法产生任何社区意识的贫瘠之物。
The tide was shifting against modernist architecture, against Robert Moses and his urban renewal policies. And soon, against the project of big government liberalism that made all of the this building possible. But for now, the United Housing Foundation and Robert Moses still had momentum and money. And their biggest project was still ahead of them. Not just their biggest project, actually, but one of the biggest residential housing developments ever constructed, 35 skyscrapers that would house more than 15,000 families. Coming up, a project that will ultimately destroy the United Housing Foundation and the cooperative housing movement that Abraham Kaysen had built.
潮流正在转向反对现代主义建筑，反对罗伯特·摩西及其城市更新政策。不久之后，也开始反对让所有这些建设成为可能的大政府自由主义项目。但就目前而言，联合住房基金会和罗伯特·摩西仍然拥有势头和资金。他们最大的项目还在前方。事实上，不仅是他们最大的项目，而且是有史以来建造的最大住宅开发项目之一，35座摩天大楼将容纳超过1.5万户家庭。接下来，一个最终将摧毁联合住房基金会以及亚伯拉罕·凯森所建立的合作住房运动的项目即将登场。
That's after the break. This is an advertisement for Freedom Land, an amusement park in the North Bronx, that aim to teach children about American history through interactive experiences. Look at that. It's the Chicago fire of 1871. Hurry up, man. We're going to need volunteers for this one. After Freedom Land went bust in 1964, Robert Moses saw an opportunity to buy a 400-acre parcel of land for relatively cheap.
休息之后继续。这是一则关于自由兰地（Freedom Land）的广告，这是布朗克斯北部的一个游乐园，旨在通过互动体验向孩子们传授美国历史。看那个。那是1871年的芝加哥大火。快点，老兄。我们需要为这个项目招募志愿者。1964年自由兰地倒闭后，罗伯特·摩西看到一个以相对便宜的价格购买400英亩土地的机会。
This would be the site of the United Housing Foundation's biggest project yet, that cluster of 35 skyscrapers that I would marvel at years later from the Greyhound bus, Co-op City. Co-op City is the largest project for the United Housing Foundation and the largest by far mortgage that is ever sponsored by Mitchell Lama. Building Co-Up City on the site of a defunct amusement park, which itself was built on a swamp, meant that no one would need to be evicted. This was basically a concession to Jane Jacobs and other critics who turned against urban renewal and slum clearance. But in many other respects, the development. The development the UHF had in mind was exactly the kind that Jacobs hated. skyscrapers set back from the street and surrounded by green space. Jacobs had warned that true community could not emerge from places like this.
这将成为联合住房基金会迄今为止最大项目的所在地，也就是我多年后从灰狗巴士上惊叹的那群35座摩天大楼——合作城（Co-op City）。合作城是联合住房基金会最大的项目，也是米切尔-拉玛赞助过的规模最大的抵押贷款项目。在一个废弃游乐园的遗址上建造合作城，而该游乐园本身又是建在一片沼泽地上，这意味着不需要驱逐任何人。这基本上是对简·雅各布斯和其他反对城市更新和清除贫民窟的批评者的一种妥协。但在许多其他方面，这个开发项目。UHF心目中的开发项目正是雅各布斯所痛恨的那种：远离街道、周围环绕着绿地的摩天大楼。雅各布斯曾警告说，真实的社区不可能从这样的地方诞生。
Co-op City opened to its first residence in December of 1968. A few months later, a blizzard hit New York. And this blizzard would be an early test of whether a community could emerge in this new development. This is Mayor John Lindsay. As I'm reporting to you over the radio this morning, our city is blanketed with a very, very heavy blanket of snow. The worst problem that we have in the city is abandoned cars. People were just leaving their vehicles right there on the road and setting out on foot all over the city, including on the stretch of I-95 that ran right past the cooperative.
合作城于1968年12月迎来了第一批居民。几个月后，一场暴风雪袭击了纽约。这场暴风雪将成为检验这个新开发项目是否能产生社区意识的早期考验。这是市长约翰·林赛。正如我今天早上通过广播向大家汇报的那样，我们的城市被厚厚的积雪覆盖。我们在城市中遇到的最大问题是废弃的汽车。人们只是把他们的车辆直接留在路上，然后徒步走遍全城，包括穿过就在合作公寓旁边的95号州际公路路段。
And the story goes that people leave the buildings, they come, they're helping, stranded. travelers. They're bringing them in. They're giving them like hot tea or hot cocoa. Meanwhile, kids are having like snowball fights. And so it becomes celebrated in this kind of Co-Upt City mythology as like the creation of a community. It was kind of proving the critics wrong. Yeah, exactly. The architecture did not stand in the way of creating a community at all. Anne-Marie wasn't there for the Blizzard, but she actually did grow up in Co-op City. And she remembers a pretty idyllic childhood there, riding her bike around the vast green spaces that surrounded the buildings, playing with the other kids, and then as a teenager, just wandering around
有传言说，人们离开大楼，过来提供帮助，帮助那些滞留的旅客。把他们接进来。给他们热茶或热可可。与此同时，孩子们在打雪仗。因此，它在合作城的这种神话中被颂扬为社区的创建。这有点证明了批评者的错误。是的，完全如此。这种建筑风格根本没有阻碍社区的建立。安娜-玛丽当时不在暴风雪现场，但她确实在合作城长大。她对那里有着相当田园诗般的童年记忆，骑着自行车穿梭于环绕建筑群的广阔绿地，与其他孩子一起玩耍，到了青少年时期，就在周围闲逛，
looking for any kind of fun. I remember being like 13 years old when there's this big mall that opened and it had the first store that opened, in my memory at least, was a hardware store. And me and all these other kids my age just went to the hardware store just to like look at wrenches or whatever because there was like nothing to do. Great place to be a kid, boring place to be a teenager. In other words, this place was basically the suburbs. Co-op City and a lot of other UHF cooperatives were providing alternatives to suburbia that helped convince the middle class to stay in the city.
寻找任何能带来乐趣的东西。我记得我13岁的时候，有一个大型购物中心开业了，在我记忆中，里面开的第一家店至少是一家五金店。我和其他同龄的孩子去五金店只是为了看扳手什么的，因为实在没事可做。作为小孩子来说是个好地方，作为青少年来说则是个无聊的地方。换句话说，这个地方基本上就是郊区。合作城和许多其他UHF合作公寓为郊区生活提供了替代方案，有助于说服中产阶级留在城市里。
When he died in 1971, Abraham Kaysen had built thousands of units of cooperative housing for middle-class New Yorkers. Co-op City had been the crowning achievements. of his vision. But he wasn't there to see it unravel. So basically, Co-Up City was built. It originally was supposed to have a $235 million mortgage. That mortgage balloons to $391 million by the time construction is completed. Building 35 skyscrapers on top of a swamp had not been easy or cheap. During the years of construction, costs rose and rows because of inflation.
1971年亚伯拉罕·凯森逝世时，他已经为纽约的中产阶级建造了数千套合作住房。合作城是他愿景的巅峰之作。但他没有亲眼看到它走向解体。所以基本上，合作城建成了。它最初的抵押贷款应该是2.35亿美元。到建设完成时，这笔抵押贷款膨胀到了3.91亿美元。在沼泽地上建造35座摩天大楼既不容易也不便宜。在建设的几年里，由于通货膨胀，成本不断上升。
And the United Housing Foundation had to take. take out a larger mortgage from the state to pay for it. A bigger mortgage for Co-Up City meant that each resident would have to pay higher carrying charges, those monthly fees that went towards the mortgage and utilities. At least that's what the state wanted. The residents disagreed. They'd been promised a certain monthly cost by the United Housing Foundation before construction even began. And how did the residents see the UHF at this time?
联合住房基金会不得不向州政府申请更大额度的抵押贷款来支付费用。合作城的贷款额变大，意味着每个居民都必须支付更高的分摊费用，也就是用于偿还抵押贷款和公用事业费用的月度费用。至少州政府是这么想的。居民们则不这么认为。在建设开始之前，联合住房基金会曾向他们承诺过一定的月度费用。那时的居民是如何看待UHF的呢？
like just another bad landlord? Yes. Yeah. They'd been duped by the United Housing Foundation. And they found the United Housing Foundation very condescending. Because if you were a resident and you went to the United Housing Foundation and you said, hey, I don't like the amount this costs or the air conditioning in my apartment isn't working or whatever complaint you had, there was this whole sort of like, you don't understand what it means to be in a cooperative. The residents of Coop City were in no mood to hear the U.S. HF's lecturing on the collective sacrifices required to live in a cooperative.
就像另一个糟糕的房东？是的。是的。他们被联合住房基金会愚弄了。他们觉得联合住房基金会非常居高临下。因为如果你是一个居民，你去找联合住房基金会说，嘿，我不喜欢这个费用或者我公寓里的空调坏了，或者你有任何投诉，就会有一种“你不懂什么是合作公寓”的姿态。合作城的居民根本没有心情听UHF长篇大论地宣扬住在合作公寓所需的集体牺牲。
Despite being shareholders or co-owners of the place, early on, the residents had very little say in what happened to it. They were not allowed to be voting members on the board that controlled the co-op that made decisions on things like whether carrying charges went up or who they would hire to repair the roof. Members of the United Housing Foundation controlled co-op cities board, and they made those kinds of decisions. I think you could argue that the UHF was in effect a kind of arm of the government.
尽管他们是这里的股东或共同所有者，但在早期，居民对这里发生的事情几乎没有什么发言权。他们不允许成为控制合作社的董事会的投票成员，董事会无法就诸如分摊费用是否上涨或雇用谁来修理屋顶等事情做出决定。联合住房基金会的成员控制着合作城的董事会，并做出了这些决定。我认为你可以认为，UHF实际上是政府的一种延伸。
You know, I mean, you know, they became so central to what the UHF did in terms of providing mortgage money and tax abatements and zoning and land clearance that in a way you could kind of argue they captured the UHF. Co-op City residents wanted the UHF to get out of their way. They wanted to run Co-UPSity themselves, and they wanted the state to give them relief. on their mortgage. Here's Co-op City resident Charlie Rosen on NBC saying basically, hey, you are the ones who wanted to keep the middle class in the city. So put your money where your mouth is. What we're telling the state legislature is either scrap the concept of moderate income housing to keep taxpaying citizens in the city or pay for it. But you cannot bring people into this type of housing and believe that it's not going to cost money. But the cost of construction was not the only thing that had changed during the years while Co-op City was being built. As the 1960s became the 1970s, New York City was teetering on the edge of bankruptcy. New York State was not much better off.
你知道，我的意思是，你知道，他们在UHF提供抵押贷款、减税、分区和土地清理方面变得如此核心，以至于在某种程度上你可以认为他们控制了UHF。合作城的居民希望UHF别再挡道。他们想自己管理合作城，并希望州政府减轻他们的抵押贷款负担。以下是合作城的居民查理·罗森在全国广播公司（NBC）上的发言，基本上是在说，嘿，你们才是想要把中产阶级留在城市里的人。所以言出必行吧。我们对州议会说的是，要么取消为了把纳税公民留在城市而建立的中等收入住房概念，要么为此买单。但你不能把人们带入这种类型的住房，却认为它不需要花钱。但在合作城建设期间，变化的不仅仅是建设成本。随着20世纪60年代过渡到70年代，纽约市正处于破产的边缘。纽约州的情况也好不到哪里去。
Essential services were being cut. Government workers laid off. State officials could hardly justify giving more money to a middle-class housing development. So the state held firm. The mortgage was what it was, and the residents of Co-op City would have to be. to find a way to pay it. In response, the residents of co-op city decided to strike. In 1975, after years of cost increases and no progress negotiating with the state, residents began withholding their monthly carrying charges. They called it a rent strike, but technically it was really
基本服务遭到削减。政府工人被解雇。州官员很难为向中产阶级住房开发项目提供更多资金进行辩护。因此，州政府立场坚定。抵押贷款就是这么多，合作城的居民必须自己想办法支付。作为回应，合作城的居民决定罢工。1975年，在经历了多年的成本上涨且与州政府谈判毫无进展后，居民开始扣留他们每月的摊款。他们称之为租金罢工，但从技术上讲，它实际上更类似于
more like a mortgage strike. Every month during the strike, the steering committee collected the carrying charges from the residents. They would collect all of these checks, but they wouldn't cash them. they would just hold all of the checks. Like, okay, well, you now, state have to negotiate with us. We have the checks, and you can't, essentially, you can't have them. Of course, New York needed those checks rather desperately. So the state did what it could to stop the strike. It assessed fines on the strike organizers,
抵押贷款罢工。罢工期间的每个月，指导委员会都会从居民那里收集摊款。他们会收集所有的支票，但不会去兑现它们。他们只是把所有的支票扣留着。就像是，好吧，现在州政府必须和我们谈判了。我们有支票，而你们基本上拿不到。当然，纽约非常急需这些支票。因此，州政府尽其所能来阻止罢工。它对罢工组织者处以罚款，
and it stopped providing certain kinds of maintenance to the buildings. The residents would have to do some things themselves. People were sort of washing the floor. in the halls of their own building and the public halls of their own buildings. You know, I think my mother chipped in, to help mock the public hall floors. This is Noel Ellison.
并且停止为大楼提供某些类型的维护。居民们不得不自己做一些事情。人们开始在自己大楼的走廊和大楼的公共大厅里清洗地板。你知道，我想我母亲也出了力，帮忙擦洗公共大厅的地板。这是诺埃尔·埃里森。
He's lived in Co-op City since the days of the strike. It kind of forced you to get to know your neighbors as well. I think I've got a picture of my mother sitting in a meeting with other wives or people from the floor. Noel remembers it all feeling really well-organized. which makes sense because a lot of the residents of Co-op City belonged to unions. They knew how to run a strike. The strike lasted 13 months.
自从罢工的日子以来，他就一直住在合作城。这倒也逼着你去了解自己的邻居。我想我有一张照片，拍的是我母亲和其他几位妻子或同楼层的人坐在一起开会。诺尔记得这一切感觉组织得非常好，这很合理，因为合作城的许多居民都属于工会。他们知道如何组织罢工。这场罢工持续了13个月。
In the end, the state agreed to help with some large repairs that were needed on the buildings. But the residents didn't get any significant relief on their mortgage. They did, however, get control of Co-op City. The United Housing Foundation was out. After the residents took over Co-op City in 1976, the UHF would not. never build another cooperative. You could say that, like, there was never a greater demonstration of the cooperative spirit than the Wrenstrike that destroyed the United's Housing Foundation.
最后，州政府同意协助进行建筑物所需的一些重大维修。但居民们的按揭贷款并没有得到实质性的减负。不过，他们确实获得了对合作城的控制权。联合住房基金会出局了。在居民于1976年接管合作城之后，联合住房基金会再也没有建造过任何其他的合作公寓。你可以说，就像雷恩罢工摧毁了联合住房基金会那样，再也没有比这更能体现合作精神的壮举了。
Co-op City itself was the cragmire from which the movement could never escape. That was it. It wasn't only that Co-op City had been a disaster for the UHF. By the mid-1970s, the project of big government liberalism was over, and a small government neoliberal era had begun. Abraham Kaysen had died. Robert Moses was more or less retired. And although many of the existing Mitchell Lama developments in New York
合作城本身就是那个运动永远无法逃脱的泥潭。就是这样。不仅因为合作城对联合住房基金会来说是一场灾难。到20世纪70年代中期，大政府自由主义的项目已经结束，小政府的新自由主义时代开始了。亚伯拉罕·凯森已经去世。罗伯特·摩西也差不多退休了。尽管纽约现有的许多米切尔-拉马开发项目
would continue to receive government subsidies, nothing new would be built under the program after the late 70s. Mitchell Lama was not the only thing to lose funding in the 1970s. A worldwide recession meant that it was a period of austerity for the whole country. and certainly for New York. The city pulled back on essential services like police and firefighters. Unemployment and crime went up. People who could leave the city did,
将继续获得政府补贴，但在70年代末之后，该计划下将不会再建设任何新项目。米切尔-拉马并不是在20世纪70年代唯一失去资金的东西。全球经济衰退意味着整个国家都处于紧缩时期，纽约当然也不例外。市政府削减了警察和消防员等基本服务。失业率和犯罪率上升了。能离开这座城市的人都离开了，
and the white flight that Robert Moses had tried to stave off finally came knocking. Co-op city was no exception. Early residents had been about 80% white, the vast majority of them Jewish, and about 20% people of color. This had been similar to the racial makeup of the Bronx at the time. But by the mid-1970s, the Bronx was changing, and so was Co-op City. By 1976, 90% of the people on the waiting list to move into Co-op City are black and Hispanic.
罗伯特·摩西一直试图阻止的白人群飞终于敲响了门。合作城也不例外。早期的居民大约80%是白人，其中绝大多数是犹太人，大约20%是有色人种。这与当时布朗克斯区的种族构成相似。但到20世纪70年代中期，布朗克斯区正在改变，合作城也是如此。到1976年，等待搬入合作城的人中有90%是黑人和西班牙裔。
Co-op City goes from being a majority white development to being one that is not, really over the course of the 1980s. While the Orthodox Synagogue on the grounds of Co-op City scaled back services for lack of congregants, The cooperative's own Harry S. Truman High School began offering a class on African American studies, and the development became a hub of early hip-hop culture. In a 1986 documentary about rap in New York City called Big Fun in the Big Town, the filmmakers interviewed a group of students from Harry S. Truman High on the grounds of Coop City. You can see the skyscrapers in the background. Here we are for fun. Guaranteed to make it any party line. So just when it's your air.
在20世纪80年代的进程中，合作城从一个白人占多数的开发区转变为一个并非如此的开发区。当合作城内的正统犹太会堂因缺少会众而缩减服务时，该合作社自己的哈里·S·杜鲁门高中开始开设非洲裔美国人研究课程，该开发区也成为了早期嘻哈文化的中心。在1986年一部关于纽约市说唱的纪录片《大镇里的巨乐》中，电影制片人在合作城的土地上采访了一群来自哈里·S·杜鲁门高中的学生。你可以看到背景中的摩天大楼。我们是为了好玩而来的。保证让它成为任何派对的热点。所以当你呼吸空气时。
If you please. And if you don't want to rock, then you might as well leave. What Co-op City was undergoing in the 1980s was indeed a racial transition. And I remember this very clearly growing up. Like when I was in eighth grade, all these families moved out. Anne-Marie says that with this racial transition came some anxiety about crime and what would become of this middle-class development. There's all these anxieties about co-op city's supposed decline, anxieties that were voiced by white residents of Co-op City for sure, but also by Black residents of Co-op City.
如果你愿意的话。如果你不想摇滚，那么你最好离开。合作城在20世纪80年代所经历的确实是一次种族转型。我在成长过程中对此记忆犹新。就像我上八年级的时候，所有这些家庭都搬走了。安妮-玛丽说，伴随着这种种族转型而来的，是对犯罪以及这个中产阶级开发项目将会变成什么的某种焦虑。对合作城所谓衰落的各种焦虑不绝于耳，这些焦虑当然是由合作城的白人居民表达的，但也是由合作城的黑人居民表达的。
And crime did go up some in the 1980s, as it did all over New York City. But a lot of this decline that people worried about at Co-op City, Ann Marie says it just never really came to pass. You know, often when you talk about neighborhoods that undergo, like, racial change, you know, where there's white flight, It's either a story of violence or a story of, you know, neglect or whatever. And Co-op City, it's not really that story. Co-op City did become a majority black community by 1990. It has remained that way to this day. But it has stayed at the same time a middle-class community.
在20世纪80年代，犯罪率确实有所上升，就像整个纽约市一样。但安妮-玛丽说，人们所担心的合作城的这种衰落，很多其实并没有真正发生。你知道，通常当你谈到经历种族变化的社区时，你知道，有白人群飞的地方，要么是一个关于暴力或疏忽的故事，诸如此类。而合作城，其实并不是那样的故事。到1990年，合作城确实成为了一个以黑人为主的社区。它一直保持这种状态直到今天。但与此同时，它依然是一个中产阶级社区。
Emory says that Co-op City's ability to stay middle-class, even as it went through a big racial transition, may have had something to do with that equity deposit. the thing that the UHF had always been so adamant about. In the early years, that deposit had been a barrier to people of color. But by the mid-1970s, the black middle class had grown, and more families could afford the upfront investment. And that investment may have helped create some stability during a decade when much of the Bronx was emptying out. It's harder to just pick up and leave when you have to sell your share
埃默里表示，合作城能够保持中产阶级属性，甚至在经历大规模种族转型时也是如此，这可能与那个股权押金有关，这也是联合住房基金会一直坚持的一点。在早期，这笔押金曾是有色人种的门槛。但到了20世纪70年代中期，黑人中产阶级已经壮大，更多的家庭能够负担得起前期投资。这种投资可能在20世纪70年代布朗克斯区大面积空心化期间带来了一些稳定性。当你必须卖掉自己的股份时，想要直接拍屁股走人就没那么容易了
or when you feel tied to a place, not just as a renter, but as a co-owner. We moved in in 1981. This is Frank Garrity. His parents, who are Puerto Rican, moved to Co-Up City during its big racial shift in the 80s, and they're still there today. So they've been there 40, what is it now? 81, since it's 45 years. Wow. Do you think the cooperative structure of the place has, like, contributed to kind of how long they've been there?
或者当你对一个地方产生归属感时，不仅是以租户的身份，而是作为共同所有者。我们是1981年搬进来的。这是弗兰克·加里蒂。他的父母是波多黎各人，在20世纪80年代合作城发生巨大种族转变时搬了进来，他们今天仍然住在那里。所以他们已经在那里待了40年，现在是多少年了？81年开始的，已经45年了。哇。你觉得这里的合作社结构，比如，促成了他们在那里住了这么久吗？
Like, that's a long time to live in a place. Yeah, absolutely. You know, they're somewhere between a tenant and an owner, you know, but I think the right word is like investment, you know, not just financial, but like a investment in a stake in a community that a typical New York tenant did not have. I don't want my parents to go anywhere. I want them to stay right in the apartment because it's affordable. And, you know, we can have health care attendants come in. And I mean, it's an ideal place still for someone of their income bracket and their stage of life to live. Frank's parents are part of a huge constituency of older residents who currently live in Co-op City. In fact, the development has become the largest naturally occurring retirement community, or Nork, in the U.S., partly because it's an affordable place to live on a fixed income in a very expensive city. There was a period during and after the rent strike when Co-op City was looked at as a failure.
比如，在一个地方住那么久是很不容易的。是的，绝对的。你知道，他们介于租户和业主之间，你知道，但我认为合适的词就像是投资，你知道的，不仅仅是财务上的，而是一种对社区权益的投资，这是典型的纽约租户所没有的。我不想让我父母去任何地方。我希望他们就留在公寓里，因为这里价格实惠。而且，你知道，我们可以请保健护工来。我的意思是，对于他们这个收入阶层和人生阶段的人来说，这里仍然是一个理想的居住地。弗兰克的父母是目前居住在合作城的庞大老年居民群体的一部分。事实上，该开发项目已经成为美国最大的自然发生的退休社区（Nork），部分原因是在一个非常昂贵的城市里，这是一个靠固定收入就能负担得起的地方。在租金罢工期间及之后的一段时间里，合作城曾被视为一个失败的案例。
The state had subsidized the building of this massive and many-thought, ugly cluster of skyscrapers. And then its residents refused for over a year to pay their own mortgage. There were politicians and pundits during the strike that suggested that government should foreclose on the mortgage and evict the residents. Walk away from this expensive project and cut its losses. And it's true that the development has needed continued subsidies from the state over the years. Building on top of a swamp has meant ongoing structural issues that residents have not been able to afford on their own. But if co-op city once served as a cautionary tale about the perils of big government ambition, it now stands as a reminder of what that kind of ambition can create.
州政府曾补贴建设了这个庞大的、许多人认为丑陋的摩天大楼群。然后，居民们却有一年多的时间拒绝支付自己的房贷。罢工期间，有政客和专家建议政府取消抵押贷款赎回权并驱逐居民。放弃这个昂贵的项目并止损。的确，多年来该开发项目一直需要州政府的持续补贴。建立在沼泽地上意味着居民无力自行承担的持续结构性问题。但是，如果合作城曾一度成为大政府雄心弊端的警世故事，那么它现在则是这种雄心能够创造什么的纪念碑。
Speaking of ambition, the new mayor of New York, Zoran Mamdani, has a plan to build 200,000 units of a portable housing over 10 years. It's a goal that former mayor Bill de Blasio also had but failed to accomplish. It won't be easy. The last time anyone built housing on this scale in New York City, well, you just heard the story of it. It was after World War II, spearheaded by people like Robert Moses and Abraham Kaysen. They made a lot of extremely harmful mistakes along the way, bulldozing neighborhoods, displacing residents, treating whole community. like they were expendable.
说到雄心，纽约新市长佐兰·马姆达尼有一个计划，要在10年内建设20万套经济适用房。这是前市长比尔·德布拉西奥也有过但未能实现的目标。这并不容易。上一次有人在纽约市以这种规模建造住房时，你刚刚听过它的故事。那是在二战之后，由罗伯特·摩西和亚伯拉罕·凯森等人带头。他们在过程中犯了许多极具破坏性的错误，推平社区，流离失所居民，把整个社区当成可以牺牲的弃子。
But the ambition to solve a housing crisis wasn't a mistake. And in a city once again wrestling with how to house the people who keep it running, the question isn't whether the government should attempt something that big again. It's whether it can afford not to. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Minkle and edited by Christopher Johnson. This episode was mixed by Martine Gonzalez with music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Some audio from this episode came from the municipal archives in New York City and the oral history archives at Columbia.
但解决住房危机的雄心并不是个错误。在一个再次纠结于如何安置维持城市运转的人的城市里，问题不在于政府是否应该再次尝试如此宏大的计划，而在于它是否承担得起不这样做的代价。《99%隐形》本周由凯蒂·明克尔制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊剪辑。本期节目由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·雷尔和乔治·兰格福德提供音乐。格雷厄姆·赫沙负责事实核查。本期节目的一些音频来自纽约市市立档案馆和哥伦比亚大学口述历史档案馆。
Thanks to Michael Rohatton for help finding archival material. Thanks also to Linda Lutton, Bernie Silich, Andy Riker, Richard Heitler, and Roseanne Boone, all of whom provided invaluable insights to this reporting. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Vivian Lay, Lashma Don, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series 6M podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building.
感谢迈克尔·罗哈顿帮助寻找档案资料。还要感谢琳达·拉顿、伯尼·西利奇、安迪·赖克、理查德·海特勒和罗珊·布恩，他们都为这篇报道提供了宝贵的见解。凯茜2世是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰妮·霍尔、维维安·莱、拉克马·唐、凯利·普赖姆、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。99%的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Series 6M播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。
In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99 p.m. at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常用的社交网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在那里有一个链接，还有99 p.m.的每一个往期节目，网址是99PI.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。